[Music]
it's time for et's social study what the
stars are posting online
leave it to Jennifer Lopez to always be
camera-ready on the red carpet the star
stepped out Monday night for NBC's
summer press day showing off her
smoking-hot body in a sexy LBD with a
daring slit then there's Ariel winter
flashing her curves abroad it's a but
everyone has a bike she posted a pic
holding a cigar while sporting a sheer
top lacy bra skirt and fishnet tights at
a bar in Beijing the Modern Family
actress appears to be enjoying her time
overseas in China while her boyfriend
shoots his upcoming film moving on
Justin Bieber debuts some fresh ink the
purpose singer shared a series of videos
on his Instagram story Monday showing
off his massive Eagle tattoo on his
chest and Mariah Carey has a treat for
fans her classic song is being turned
into an animated film
Mimi revealed on Twitter there's and all
I want for Christmas movie in the works
set to release this holiday season I
don't want a lot for Christmas there is
just one thing I need
you
[Music]